من بعد اسبوعين على الدراما اللي صارت بين
شاكيرا وبيك بسبب اغنيتها الي سرقتها
مؤخرا وهاجمت فيها بكى وجابت اكثر من 200
مليون مشاهده ورد بيك عليها بتحويل
الموضوع لمكسب والشركات اللي دخلت في
الموضوع وغيرها يبدو انه الدراما مستمره
وما خلصت ولا زلنا على موعد مع حركات
وردات فعل من الطرفين وهذه المره الرد جاء
من بيكي وعبر حساباته لاول مره
لحبيبته الجديده كلارا شيء على الانستغرام
وصوره يعني الحب والانسجام واضح فيها جدا
كانت بيكي لشاكيرا مع الفتاه هذه هو سبب
انفصالهم بعد العلاقه اكثر من 10 سنين
وولدين ومن دون ما يكتب بيكي اي تعليق على
الصوره لكن الرساله وصلت يعني هو الاعتراف
واضح وصريح بالعلاقه بين الاثنين وفكركم
مثلا شاكيرا سكتت من بعد بوستيه قامت
شاكيرا ونشرت بوست علقت فيه وكتبت النساء
بيرقصوا ونشرت فيديو لها وهي بترقص
ههه
[موسيقى]
تحدي تحدي
نفسي كنا صغيره في العمر واسمها صار على
كل لسان في اسبانيا بسبب الاغنيه كل هذا
اللي شايفينو انه لسه هذا الطريق لانه
كمان في اخبار بتقول انه شاكيرا بتجهز
اغنيه جديده وهذه عاد راح تنزل في يوم عيد
ميلادها اللي هو نفسه يوم عيد ميلاد اللي
هو اثنين فبراير
[موسيقى]